[Music]
[Applause]
my name is Beth Wathan and I'm the owner
of the city of year store and today I'm
going to show you a brief introduction
on how to tap a keg so this is our
particular unit we're going to be using
here obviously this isn't something that
most people have at home what I'm doing
today is I'm tapping this IPA which I
will be using an American thank you
tapping device for that so the first
thing you've got this little knob up
here we've got the little ball right
there in the top but that's what you
want to adhere the device to so i'm
gonna snap it in I'm gonna lock it up
when you feel it catch you're gonna pull
and release and lock in the lever now
tapped ready for action so now I'm just
going to do a quick demonstration on how
to tap I can get home
which I'm sure a lot of you are familiar
with having attended various cake
parties over the years what we're gonna
do is we're gonna pop this little guy
and lock it into place right here at the
top it's going to attach itself again to
the bulb right there
so setting it in be right there and then
I'm gonna lock it into place so it's
just just like a church key twist it
turn it and then we're gonna release the
lever which is the final walking process
so up down and then at that point you
might want to do a couple quick pumps
just to make sure that you do release
some of the air alright the first glass
or two might be a bit foamy so we're
just gonna that kind of pour those two
off you'll see that right there what
we're tapping today is just a
traditional American style but if you're
tapping something say for example a
Belgian beer Belgian beers a lot of
times are their keg conditioned and so
they still have a lot of the carbonation
that exists within the keg so when
you're tapping it and you're not using a
bar system you're just using a hand pump
you you're gonna get a lot of fun a lot
of resistance in the beer so it's
something we don't typically recommend
if you don't have a professional system
setup at home we also change our lines
every two years
you just want to make sure because even
even if you're doing all the proper
cleaning it's still things do they wear
down over time you know get kind of like
a cardboard e dusty flavor in your beer
that's how you know that the beer is
either old or that the liens haven't
been cleaned German beers and beers from
Europe they have a different topping
device it's called a slider so it just
connects a little bit differently then
this one
another type of tapping you could do is
nitrous which we don't have that type of
system here but that's another option
you'll see in bars where you have a
example of a Guinness Guinness is always
poured on nitro so it's just a thick
creamy foam there's not fully minimal
minimal carbonation in there it's just a
big nice milk shaky beer so when you're
pouring a pint in this case and you're
pouring this ginormous mug here you want
to make sure you do a bit of tilting
because you want to ensure that the beer
doesn't have a huge foamy head in this
particular case you are going to want to
see a nice creamy top so you're going to
want to leave a little bit of room to
kind of let the beer open up and I'm
going to do a final pour
and there we have it
[Applause]
[Music]